you punching brush
yeah
good job
good job
please knock that right off there
yeah
okay hold that yep there's your butt
there's your butt
you want brush and water at the same
time or is that too distracting
seriously you guys
she loves
this brush
more than anyone has ever loved anything
every single time i walk past this area
she jumps up on the sink and looks at me
please
yeah
yeah
yeah oh my goodness
oh my goodness
yeah
yeah
oh she likes a brush on the side of the
face look at that face
look at that face
i know
brush is the best thing ever it's the
best thing ever
yeah
how is it
on that side now okay well i can't
she's like what's going on
oh god if i hardly like recorded like
russia at the same time
but i wanted to get some footage of this
because she's so funny about it
yeah
just oh
oh
yeah i know it's very satisfying
very satisfying
and look there's i installed one on the
wall too so she could like
brush herself at the same time so she
could have like a two-pronged brush
attack
so she seems to like that like all brush
on one side and then she'll rub on that
on the other side of her face
yeah
let me get your bib
got your bib a little bit
yeah
yeah
what you
doing what you doing
yeah
you went downside down be careful
you can't go
she's like don't take it away oh
okay we're coming over here now
okay you're done okay bye